[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد في افغانستان تواصلوا
حركه طالبان تنفيذه سياستها غير المشروع
عام من خلال اغلاق ابواب المدارس
والجامعات امام الفتيات وتعليق عمل النساء
الا ان منظمه انقذوا الاطفال قالت انها
تلقت تاكيدات من طلبان بان موظفتها يمكنهن
العمل دون عوائق وفي السياقه لنائب
المتحدث باسم طالبان بلا كريم في مقابله
خاصه بها قناه العربيه في وقت سابقا قال
ان الحركه تسعى لتنظيم المراحل التعليميه
وشؤون التعليميه بما يتوافق مع احكام
الشريعه الاسلاميه رافضا مقوله ان طالبان
ضد العلم والتعليم المسؤول اشار الى انا
طالبان منحت المراه حقوقها لم تكون موجوده
في السابق كما انه من واجبها تنظيم شؤون
تعليم وتنميه في البلاد وفقني احكام
الشريعه واكد ان الحركه ستبحث الانتقاداته
لطالبان بشان قرار تعليم المراه في ذا
تتواصلوا الدعوات الدوليه حيث حتى مجلس
الامن الدولي حركه الطالبان على انهاء
المعامله القمعيه ضد النساء في افغانستان
بعد قرار ابعثهن من مجالات الحياه العامه
ومنعهن من التعليمه والتراجع الفوري عن
جميع الاجراءات القمعيه ضد النساء
والفتيات واحترام حقوقهن ومشاركتهن في
جميع جوانب المجتمع
الاسلامي
في الماضي وانتم تعلمون ان الامارات
وحقها في الزواج وحقها في الحريه وفي
مجالات اخرى
ايوه
نظرالاسلاميه تتكون من علماء وطلاب يهتمون
بالعلوم والتربيه والتعليم اكثر من اي فئه
اخرى والاماره لا تعارض تعليم اي شخص باي
شكل من الاشكال ولكنها مسؤوله عن تنظيم
المراحل التربويه والتعليميه وكل ما يتعلق
بذلك فهي مسؤوله وترى ان من واجبها ان
يكون ذلك وفقا لاحكام الشريعه الاسلاميه
والمبادئ الاسلاميه
هناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من كابول
صحفيه محب الله الشريف اهلا بيكم معنا هنا
في الاستوديو السيد نور الله سراب الباحث
السياسي الافغاني اهلا بكم ضيفاي واسمحالي
ان ابدا من كابول معك ااا سيد محب الله
لفهم هذه التصريحات في الواقع السيد بلال
الكريمي يتحدث عن ان اام
طالبان تتفهم وجوب تعليم المراه ولكن في
نفس الوقت يجب ان يكون التعليم موافق
لقراءه الحركه وما يتناسب مع الشريعه
الاسلاميه طيب ان كان ذلك فعلا لماذا
منعت المراه من التعليم كليه لماذا لم
تتحدث مثلا عن اعاده دراسه جديده
سعيد محب الله هل تسمعني طيب سنعود لك بعد
قليل سيكون سؤال لك سيد
كلاب
لماذا طالبان تتحدث وتتراجع فيما بعد
تتحدث عن اهميه التعليم وفيما بعد تقول
بانه هذا التعليم لا يتناسب مع المجتمع
الافغاني
القضيه كلها تعود الى فراغ دستوري عندما
لا يكون هناك دستور في الدوله وان لا تكون
هناك
مؤسسه تنظم اعمال الدوله تجاه مواطنيها
وايضا خدماتها وايضا اعمال المواطنين تجاه
الدوري
فلهم سنه ونصف الغوا الدستور القديم لا
يوجد عندهم دستور جديد كلام فتفاظ ان كل
شيء سيتم في ضوء الشريعه الاسلاميه هل
انتم الان مثل علماء المملكه او مثل علماء
مصر مثل علماء الدول العربيه الذين
يستطيعون ان يستنبط الاحكام في كل حادثه
وفوريه وحدثيا قرانيه لا كلها هؤلاء
المشايخ الذين الان موجودون في السلطه لا
يستطيعون ان يستخرجوا حكم واحد خلال اسبوع
هم يجلسون وياخذون فتره طويله حتى يستنبط
حكم معين لقضيه معينه
غير موافق للشريعه الاسلاميه وهم ان
المشكله ان المراه يجب ان لا تتعلم المراه
يجب ان لا تخرج اذا كان يتحدث هذا لا
كانهم اعطه حقوق اكثر للمراه في افغانستان
من اي نظام سابق وفي هذه المرحله عندما
يدعون ان الحقوق منحت لها وهي محرومه من
الدراسه في المدرسه محرومه من الدراسه في
الجامعه محرومه من العمل في القطاع
الحكومي محرومه من العمل في المؤسسات
الخيريه محرومه من العمل في الامم المتحده
فاذا كانت الحقوق مع لها بهذا الشكل وهي
محرومه اذا كانت اذا لم يكن هناك يحق
ممنوح لها بايش كان همم تسمعني
نعم صوت واضح لديك
هنا يطرح فكره عدم توافق تصريحات حركه
طالبان مع افعالها يقول بان الحركه ما
يهمها هو عدم دراسه المراه ولا علاقه
المناهج الدراسيه بذلك هم حتى لا يدركوا
ما الذي تضمنه هذه المناهج
اسمحوا لي ان اكون حدا وسط بين كلمات
ضيفكم وبين حركه طالبان في كابول
بالفعل هناك كانت وعود امام المجتمع
الدولي وامام الشعب الافغاني من قبل
الحركه الطالبان اثناء المفاوضات بان هناك
سوف تكون حقل التعليم المراه وكذلك العمل
لها يعني وامور كثيره جدا لكن بعد ما
توغلت حركه طالبان في العاصمه الافغانيه
وسيطرت على افغانستان هي اغلقت بعد ذلك
ابواب المدارس ما فوق الصف السادس همم
امام الفتيات وكذلك بعد ذلك جاءت خطوه
اخرى ضربه اخرى
باغلاق الجامعات امام الفتيات وبعد ذلك
الخطوه الثالثه من عملهن في المؤسسات غير
الدوليه في المحليه او الدوليه فالامر صار
يعني صعب جدا
وحركه طالبان منذ امد بعيد لم تستطيع ان
تعطي خطه عمليه
لاعاده مدارس البنات وكذلك الجامعات
وعملهن في الادارات الدوليه هذا الامر
يعني صار عبئا كبيرا على حركه طالبان وانا
لا اعتقد ان هناك شخصيات في حركه طالبان
يعني تخالف تماما تعليما المراه او دوري
المراه بين القوسين في المجتمع الافغاني
انا لا انا انكر هذا بصوره كامله بل اقول
ان هناك نعم شخصيات في حركه طالبان هي لا
تريد ان تكون المراه الافغانيه على ذلك
القدر الذي كان في ايام الحكومه الجمهوريه
في افغانستان لكن لو اعيدت الحقوق لها
بالحجاب والقسم الخاصه لها نحن لا يعني
نخالف ذلك لكن
سيد همم
ضيف يتحدث عن شبه انقسام داخل الحركه
نفسها وعلى فكره هذا همم اا استخلاص اهو
عديدون ممن تحدثوا الى الحركه الى اعضاء
الحركه بان هناك همم شق همم مع همم تعليم
المراه وشق اخر من قيادات الصف الاول الذي
يرفض ذلك تماما هل هذا الانقسام حاصل
فعليا
الانقسام لابد منه ولابد من اختلاف الفكر
في التوجهات الرسميه لحركه طالبان لان
كلها هؤلاء ليسوا علماء وليسوا كلهم مشايخ
وليسوا كلهم مولويه ولا وليس كلهم الملالي
لان النصفهم كانوا مليشيات فقط يقاتلون من
اجل همم بقيه زملائهم اما لا يوجد هناك
شيء شرعي ان كلها هؤلاء كانوا خريج
مدارسنا كلها هؤلاء كانوا يدرسون في منهج
معين ان كلها هؤلاء كانوا طلاب ابدا هذه
مليشيات تقاتل لمصلحه ما انا يعني لا
يؤيدهم انهم كلهم كانوا على توجه اسلاميه
وان كلها هؤلاء كانوا فعلا في ضمن قائمه
ترى بان هذه شقاقات تراها شبه عاديه ولكن
هل هذه الشق الانشقاقات قادره ان همم تدفع
بضغوط في داخل الحركه لتعود عن هذا القرار
الان هناك يعني شخصيات استثنائيه في
الحركه هم يريدون ان تكون هناك مؤسسات
تعمل والمراه تعمل وتدرس وهؤلاء ليس لهم
صوت قوي لان المله الكبير الذي جالس في
قندر ولا احد يعرف عنوانه هو الذي يسري
الفتاوي وهو الذي يشتري القرارات الحاسمه
في القضايا المسيريه للوطن وهذا الرجل
الذي جالس في هل هو طبعا لم يعيش في
افغانستان خلال الاربعين سنه الماضيه ولا
يعرف طبيعه المواطن الافغاني الذي تدرب
وتاهل وتدرج في المناسب والوظائف والتعليم
وان هناك التغيير الجذري في الثقافه
الافغانيه ويتحدث عن اشياء قديمه كانت
موجوده قبل 200 سنه هذه الاشياء الان غير
موجوده الشعب تغيره والتطور بان اعطينا
حقوق المراه اكثر من ما كانت تتحدث عما
قبل 40 سنه
الحقوق التي للمراه الحق الاساسي التعليم
الحق الاساسي اللي عمل الحق الاساسي الذي
التحرر في الوطن بحريه كامله انت باي حق
تمنع ملايين الناس من التعليم ملايين
الناس من العمل ملايين الناس من من العيش
الكريم في هذا الوطن والناس كل يوم يخرجون
من وطنك انت يجب ان تكون قراراتك مدروسه
حسب متطلبات الشعب الافغاني حسب
احتياجاتهم فانت جالس في مكان مجهول
الاقامه تعالي للشعب الافغاني يواجههم
معك استاذ شريف لبعض يتحدث عن الضغوط
الدوليه التي قد تؤدي الى عوده حركه
طالبان عن قرارها منع المراه عن الدراسه
خاصه وان الحركه تسعى لفتح المجال لعودتها
لحضن الدولي هل هذا ممكن
انا اعتقد ان الضغوط يعني بهذه الصوره
التي يعتبرها البعض من خارج افغانستان انا
لا اعتبرها مؤثره لانني يعني ارى حركه
وقريب منها منذ يعني التسعينيات للمره
الاولى في كابول والمره الثانيه كذلك انا
في كابول واراها وسياساتها وخطواتها انا
اعتبر ان المفاوضات بصوره ايجابيه ومفتوحه
ويعني على كل المدارات سوف يكون الحل
الوسط متابعه
شريف ومن الاسود جنرالله سلام الباحث
السياسيه الافغاني شكرا لكم للنقاش دائما
السلام عليكم